he knows he hasn't been at his best but
oh is he a smile for me on the publicity
we do okay well maybe well he is ready
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
think about what he's been doing in his
break oh he does have some key in front
of him very good he's staying off the
alcohol and they're playing what's
happening that's right so both sides
pushing their pawns in front of their
kings on the first turn
one of the most classic openings we go
into an opening is called the berlin
wall
and it's called the berlin wall because
black's position is so hard to break
down it's so solid um i'm very surprised
that pogba actually is even allowing
this he's going for it because the
berlin wall magnus carson he's one of
the leading experts i think he could
often he could draw this position in his
sleep he could hold this position napoli
actually though
maybe he knows his chances passed he
hasn't gone for the most aggressive
attempt but he's hoping
beyond hope that somehow magnus castle
maybe relaxes too early um i don't like
the opening choice from napoli actually
going into this berlin wall i think he's
just going to run up against that wall
and fail to break it down
magnus carson meanwhile
just advancing his night there attacking
white's pawn in the center of the board
normally lots of pieces get traded early
on in the game
this is not the most ambitious start to
find the pontiac i'm very surprised in a
must-win situation he's allowing such a
solid defense for magnus carson maybe
he's in the kind of realm of let it be
just
just play a game and see how it pans out
and just
abandon any attempt at uh
putting in any effort that's right but
this has all been um worked out this
position
um okay napoli actually very surprised
by magnus carson's last move there in
the world and
i did get a chance i was part of a team
it was just a bit of an experiment i got
to play against alpha zero this
artificial intelligence program and i
used this opening as white to make a
draw
with white you use this opening to try
and make a draw so it's that's why it
shocks me so much that the pontiac has
entered this line four pawns in nearly
the same formation as each other and
okay the pieces are being traded off one
of the things you do not want is you do
not want simple positions where your
opponent it's easy for your opponent to
make a move have both left the board and
now with this last move magnus carlsen
offering this queen trade the queens are
looking at each other
uh janna pomnichi says no no queen
trades for you but uh more important
than even the queen trade is the fact
that the pawns are completely
symmetrical for example if magnus carson
pushes his pawn now look at the okay he
does this look at those pawns all of
black's pawns exactly
they're exactly copying the white
structure that means there's no chance
to open up more lines there's no way to
unbalance things just the fact normally
symmetrical pawn structures like this
mean the composition is completely level
um i don't
think that neanderthal will get anywhere
near to any winning chances here it's a
very solid stuff from magnus carson
i don't think he has anything to
complain about here final match and just
going all in on day two it's getting
close to that stage already but it still
means that a position is easy
that's right normally especially at this
level in order to win a game of chess
you need some action happening you see
some open lines all you need for example
you need a bishop in exchange for your
opponent's knight here both sides have
exactly the same material exactly the
same pawns black will use a pawn to kick
that rook back okay um and there we see
it there we see it okay so still will we
see some fireworks now
yep it's retreated to the second square
so what is getting ready to line up the
rook on the left hand side of the board
next to it so i agree with you i think
this is gonna see will it be a quick
draw or will will they try to play this
out a little bit
i think they'll try to play they will
try to play it out but this kind of
chess is like very it's like the vacuum
cleaner has come on the board
gotten much attention i have to say
that's right and um
there we see black's last move he is
attacking the white queen with his
knight i'm a bit surprised by that last
decision by magnus carson we see the
queens have left the board though and
although the bar the green bar below the
two players it's slightly zoomed over to
white side but i don't think that's
enough yes it's always a good idea to
play chess yeah just enjoy the game okay
so we see a flurry of moves
the bishop did in fact take the rook and
nam pomniacci is trying to make progress
by
advancing his king aside pawns
doubled pawns on that line in front of
the white king but those double pawns
aren't weaknesses they all protect each
other um magnus advancing on the left
now
yeah the chances are disappearing move
by move for napoliacci also the clock
situation magnus carson has more time
than he started with
um he
apology won't be able to put pressure on
the clock this game
i mean i think the thing is though you
need to keep the rooks
on the board if you're gonna make any
attempt at winning this okay and he has
advanced the pawn on the left hand side
i really like just pushing this pull
forward one square black's knight is
slightly uh constricted now it cannot
jump forward because it's controlled by
a pawn you cannot jump forward to this
square either it's controlled by a pawn
and likewise it's controlled by a lot of
pawns right now so
white is constricting that knight also
white might try to advance a pawn of his
own it's not even the finger moves the
mouse movements it's just the looking my
clock the board my clock the board
that song will be stuck to my brain
we should all do it okay one two three
my clock for most things but we have
seen a set of pawns leave the board um
we have seen a trade on the right-hand
side there
fair trade pawn for porn but the
position isn't completely symmetrical
anymore um if we bring up the board just
to see what's happened
magnus carlsen he did try to open up the
position he's trying to force the matter
he's trying to end the game as quickly
as possible by making a draw so he
pushed the pawn forward these pawns left
the board but i don't like that decision
the pawn this pawn is doubled we
mentioned that on the same line he
black is helping white to remove a
double pawn and after the capture white
moves his rook across maybe he wants to
push this pawn forward we've seen a
couple more moves that pushes on the
right hand side
white improves his bishop
still not so much going on we that's
reflected in the bar in the middle there
0.0 okay 0.2 it's not a huge amount
happening the pawn on the right hand
side of the board
could potentially
one day
in a pipe dream
make itself into an outside passport
that's right if we
uh
very it needs a lot of assistance one
percent chance maybe yeah all right well
we know that janna pognancy has to win
this game if he wants to equal the first
semi-final day match if it is a draw or
minus wins the magnus will win
day one
that's right and actually we have seen a
trade white has
uh exchanged his own bishop for black's
knight the more trades that happened
we've mentioned it a few times the more
trades that happen the closer we're
edging towards the draw
magnus pushing a pawn on the left side
there
white could capture it it looks like
white would win a pawn
but black's rook will whizz across to
the end and start to take those pawns
well especially for janna pognachu then
you said it so many times it's sometimes
just about forgetting everything it
absolutely is
but it's easier said than done okay so
pawn has advanced and so we see a flurry
of trades
that's right a few pawns have left the
board now that left-hand side is all
just starting to disappear um ivanka
mentioned it the vacuum cleaner result
just hovering up all those pawns
watch finals he did make a comeback he
was fantastic on day two so the black
rook has gone to the left-hand side of
the board and is now looking at an open
line so this is this is relatively good
news there's so few pieces on the board
kind of has a threat here it's not a
huge threat just a small one but he's
doing the right thing rooks need these
open lines he wants to jump down and
attack the white king
rooks are so great at covering
lots of territory in one move that rook
is going to swing up the board
that rook's gonna maybe give check to
the white king therefore white tries to
distract black he's pushing a pawn
forward he's offering more trades and
the game is fizzling out napoleon
actually starting to come to terms with
that yeah who who is it that will offer
the draw here magnus carson maybe if he
offered the draw it might be a bit
not disrespectful but it just might be a
bit presumptuous thinking okay i know
this is draw but i'm ahead
so napoli actually the bonus is on him i
think to make that draw offer and
sometimes that's a bit of a difficult
perhaps a distraction
and so you're just like okay well if
they want to draw we'll repeat the
position three times well we will pay
attention to that it's it's not
happening yet
no that's right and actually
magnus carson is the one maybe playing
for the win he's the only one with
winning chances here we see black's king
is very active black's king on the
left-hand side there it's actually made
a journey across the board
targeting one of white's pawns and
that's why white has retreated his
knight to defend his own pawn on the
left side there
so yeah i agree with you david that was
absolutely brilliant you know the king
has made a brilliant jet but it took a
step backwards
and as jovanka mentioned if this pawn
disappears black will be left with an
unrivalled very very dangerous past pawn
the danger on the board might not be
that great but
the psychological danger could be like
the could be greater than the actual
threat it looks like a pawn sacrifice
for white but it's just a trade um we
have seen that happen white's just going
to capture this remaining black pawn um
everything's disappearing the whole
left-hand circle all the pawns have been
obliterated and two pawns versus two
pawns on the same side of the board is
just a dead draw neither side can make
progress there
neither side can get their pawn to the
end of the board yeah the only the only
thing that i can see is that the black
king has been caught on the wrong side
of the board it would be a lot more
comfortable if it were on the right hand
side looking at its own pawns but magnus
has it under control in fact he is now
attacking the white knight this time
though the knight does retreat it is
very safe there
we don't like our knights on the edge of
the board knights are very bad at the
edge of the board they can only cover
four squares compared to the normal
eight squares but
um
we will see another set of pawns leave
the board most likely
and the game the last game between
wesley sony car and nakamura it did end
in a draw and